i'm ahmad ali yukfur and i host the see
something say something podcast at
buzzfeed news i'm here with my sister
zanub hi and we're going to be making
our moms eid lamb biryani islam is an
abrahamic religion and ida celebrates
abraham's sacrifice of the lamb and his
son and so during that holiday muslims
basically take the meat of a butchered
animal and donate a charity and share
food with family friends and your
neighbors so biryani to me feels like
turkey on thanksgiving when we at our
house on thanksgiving we'd always have a
turkey but also a biryani and like you
were saying every family has their own
recipe there are people who have like
their special tricks and they swear like
their version is like the best version
and like definitely people won't ever
tell you their full recipe or like
they'll leave out their secret
ingredient that makes it their special
biryani but it comes out on special
occasions like a turkey so when i
celebrate eat i usually send some money
to like a farm to donate some meat to a
family in need it can take different
forms some people do a cow some people
do a goat some people do a lamb
but the ultimate thing is to share
meat with people who need it and the
people who are close to you the
tradition has become
to slaughter an animal and to give the
meat to friends and family and to
charity but the real kernel of truth or
importance to that tradition is to feed
those in need so usually every year i
donate to a place like city harvest or
something so that hungry new yorkers can
eat
either not only celebrates that
abrahamic story but also celebrates the
end of hajj it's on the tenth day of the
hija which is a month in the islamic
calendar and the people who are doing
the pilgrimage is the last day of the
pilgrimage the day they celebrate having
completed the pilgrimage it's a very
happy holiday people come together share
food celebrate all around the world in
pakistani communities in america and
back home you're going to be seeing
people eat a lot of biryani and lamb and
goat so when we celebrate eid we wake up
and go to the mosque in the morning meet
our community
people from all around the world and
then we go to parties usually where
people are usually serving meat to a
bunch of guests when we host a party we
usually serve like three to five
different types of meat that are like
really complicated and complex and
delicious and biryani is usually the
center of that there's like as many
biryanis as there are people in india
found in
yeah the subcontinent
and there's so many ways to make it our
mother passed away about a decade ago
almost now she was a very good cook and
we have some of her recipes in our head
but biryani was something that was so
special and rare that i don't think i at
least knew it so i was really excited
when i found it in this recipe book that
her and a bunch of other pakistani
doctors had put together
actually the recipe we're making is not
exactly like the one that i remember
because she never shared her secrets she
never told anyone a full recipe ever
biryani is definitely something that i
associate as a party food when guests
are visiting our house that's what my
mom would make it yeah it's a way to
celebrate you put so much energy and
time into all the different steps and
the layers of flavor and that's like
another way of showing your family and
your friends how much you love them and
care about them
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you